Good morning, Hank. It's Tuesday.
Today’s video is like the human sternum:
It comes to you in three parts.
Part one: The Manubrium.
So, the Tenth Annual Project for Awesome (Nerdfighteria’s annual charity event) begins at noon Eastern
Time on Friday.
That’s when you should upload your Project
for Awesome videos and submit them to projectforawesome.com,
but the Indiegogo fundraiser will go live
at midnight tonight, and you can get lots
of great perks for donating, including a Project
for Awesome tote bag, P4A socks, an exclusive
episode of Dear Hank & John, and an audio
recording of me reading about fifteen pages
from a thing I’m working on.
Wait a thing? What thing?
“Thing” isn’t a very descriptive noun!
Yeah, I know, it’s intentionally undescriptive.
Moving on!
Part Two: The Body.
The middle of the sternum is called the body?
Anatomists are so bad at naming.
So during the first half of the Project for
Awesome, all the money raised will be split
between Save the Children and Partners in
Health, two organizations doing amazing jobs
of helping the most vulnerable children and
families around the world.
And thanks to matching donations, I am pleased
to announce that during the first half of
the P4A, your donations will be worth much
more money.
A group of nerdfighters has gotten together
with Hank and me to offer $300,000 in matching
donations, and generous donors from both Partners
in Health and Save the Children will also
match your donations, meaning that starting
at midnight tonight, every dollar you donate
to the Project for Awesome is worth four dollars.
So thank you to all our matching donors.
Part Three: The Xiphoid Process, which would
be a pretty good name for a band.
It’s time for my holiday book roundup.
This year, I want to recommend twelve books
that I think will make excellent holiday gifts.
Let’s start with my three favorite grownup
fiction books of the year.
First, Underground Railroad by Colson Whitehead,
which just won the National Book Award.
It is a haunting and brilliant novel about
American slavery that imagines the underground
railroad as an actual underground railroad.
Second, Moonglow by Michael Chabon (Chabon?).
One of the problems with being a proper genius
like Michael Chabon is that after you publish
several nearly perfect novels, people start
saying, “Oh yeah, it’s another nearly perfect movel;
he’s written a bunch of those.”
But no, this is an amazing book about war
and memory and mental illness. I loved it.
And lastly, What Is Not Yours Is Not Yours
by Helen Oyeyemi, which is just a transfixing
book of fairy tale-like short stories.
I promise you have never read anything like
it before.
For Sci-Fi fans, another story collection
recommendation: Ted Chiang’s Stories of Your Life and Others.
One of the stories in that book was the basis
for the wonderful movie Arrival, but they’re
all mind-blowingly good.
My other favorite Sci-Fi of the year was Nnedi
Okorafor’s Binti, which is about a girl
who has to travel across the galaxy to attend
university.
It’s page-turny and exciting, but ultimately
really moving.
Young adult fiction!
I liked a lot of young adult books this year,
but I’m gonna limit myself to three recommendations.
First, Ember in the Ashes, a thrilling and
politically astute dystopian series.
Then there’s The Raven Cycle by Maggie Stiefvater
for fantasy fans.
It’s just amazing.
And if you’re looking for a good YA love
story, I recommend The Sun Is Also a Star.
For fans of YouTubers, there are lots of great
books out there by YouTubers, but I wanna
highlight Hannah Hart’s Buffering because
I think it’s a beautifully written and extraordinarily
touching memoir.
Okay, nonfiction.
Two stand out for me this year.
First, I Contain Multitudes, a history of
microbes and humanity’s relationship with them.
That is a fascinating book, even if, like
myself, you are not thrilled by the notion
that half the cells inside of your body are
not, strictly speaking, yours.
And secondly, Sapiens, a sweeping history
of the last 250 thousand or so years that
explores how humans became the dominant species
on the planet, and also what our lives looked
like back when we were, in the author’s
phrase, “an animal of no significance.”
And lastly, you know how you have, or I hope
you have, a quirky and delightful friend who
is just the most fascinating person you know?
I have the perfect gift book for that person.
Textbook Amy Krouse Rosenthal, a wonderfully
eccentric memoir that is enhanced by texting, really.
So Hank, those are twelve books I recommend
this holiday season.
You will see me on Friday for the Tenth Annual
Project for Awesome!
Endscreen!
Here’s a couple guides on how to make a
good Project for Awesome Video, and a link
to the Indiegogo will be here once it’s
live.
And of course Self-Care Bunny hope you’re
being nice to yourself and eating your carrots,
unless you’re allergic to carrots.